attention question quel rappeur tient
son nom d'une chanson de Chantal
exactement exactement
ça sera génial ouais il y a pas une
sorte de droit contraste c'est aller
petit René la taupe c'est toi aussi
il est venue j'ai chanté ça je la fais
la chanson de Booba
a déjà fait un rap devant Gims
tous les chansons de la plaine c'est une
révolution car ce bâtard elle a pas a
tué un chasseur c'était un lapin qui
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
merci à toi merci parce que j'avais
balancé 2012
[Rires]
vrai ou faux en pleine cavale Jacques
Mesrine a sonné chez Chantal
que j'embrasse
et Jean-Jacques maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à la maison j'habitais Houdan c'était
une heure du matin j'ai vu une voiture
arrivée c'est tout seul et puis je me
disais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça et
alors j'ai pas reconnu mais sa tête me
parlait et puis dans la cuisine il m'a
demandé où est la route de attends quand
même un gars qui était chez toi
il est en train de manger un gigot dans
la cuisine
il est arrivé et puis il me demande la
route pour aller à Nantes la jolie je
dis je connais c'est par là non je vais
chercher un plan vous allez me montrer
ah j'ai essayé ça va être bizarre je
vais mettre la tête en avant et me
donner un coup là j'ai été comme ça
non je vais vous accompagner c'est plus
simple ma voiture vous me suivez mais je
suis pas allé et puis tout d'un coup il
m'a dit pas vous direz bonjour à
quelqu'un je connais bien Jean-Jacques
et toi tu as vu un gars en fait elle est
toujours ouverte chez moi parce que moi
je veux pas ah non si il y a le feu moi
je peux partir au courant dans tout est
fermé
[Rires]
avec lui donc le voleur
de lui dire vous avez dû connaître mes
chansons quand vous étiez petit il m'a
dit comment ça mais je dis ben Pandi
panda Bécassine surtout le lapin Julie
lapin qui a tué le chasseur évidemment
qu'on connaît
le fou de l'histoire c'est que le
lendemain j'avais à déjeuné avec Rémi
grimbach le réalisateur de télé il dit
je peux pas passer dans ta forêt j'ai
mais pourquoi il y a une forêt c'est
facile non il y a au moins 500 ça
s'enflamique pareil que quelqu'un est
très important mais je sais pas c'est
Jacques Mesrine voilà à deux ans près
quel âge avait Chantal quand elle a
sauvé la vie de ses parents
mais moi j'étais sur une plantation très
isolée de caoutchouc ma mère m'avait
caché m'a dit tu sors surtout pas ce
qu'elle sait que j'étais au Vietnam hein
je suis sortie évidemment pas quand on
me dit il faut pas faire ça moi je le
fais tout de suite
avec des fusils j'ai dit puis papa est
arrivé à tacher j'ai dit mais ça c'est
mon papa il m'a dit on va pas on va voir
si on va s'en occuper si vous tuerai
jamais mon père bon ça papa je la
prépare pas
française avec qui on le colocation chez
Chantal pendant un an
et il me disait comme on repart
l'appartement fait beaucoup de travaux
est-ce qu'on peut habiter chez toi bon
Sylvie était aux États-Unis et puis on
était très amis ce que nos enfants sont
nés en même temps mon fils et David ils
sont né en même temps un mois près mais
du coup j'ai dit à Johnny bah viens
habiter bah alors là dis donc
j'ai deux copains qui peuvent venir
mettre une belle moquette à l'époque
c'est comme ça rue des Saints
biker
toute la cour ils sont montés le
lendemain il y avait des traces partout
je dis bon on s'en fout on changera la
moquette que je te dis oui t'inquiète
pas mais moi j'aime beaucoup Johnny
parce que c'était un vrai ami de notre
jeunesse comme nous nous étions petits
Chantal Goya il faut aller la voir c'est
demain après demain c'est le dernier
dernière représentation de Chantal pour
faire une vidange
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu m'amèneras ton rapport de stage quand
même même les Bains
[Musique]
du plateau
méfiez-vous il va prendre la place de
quelqu'un